d'ici quelques mois ce bâtiment vétuste
sera entièrement détruit mais les
contrôlent désormais obligatoire avant
ce type d'opération ont révélé la
présence d'amiante dans les murs alors
la collectivité territoriale de
martinique a commandé auprès d'une
entreprise privée
le désamiantage avant toute opération de
démolition on est en train de monter sur
la structure d'échafaudage ce qu'on
appelle du pôle yann thermorétractable
dakar qui est mis en place pour réduire
le volume d'air une fois qu'il est posé
eh ben on le chauffe de manière à ce
qu'ils se rétractent et ce qui va nous
rendre l'étanchéité du bâtiment c'est la
mise en place d'extracteurs d'air qui
vont nous renouveler chaque heure 6 fois
le volume d'air total le confinement
devrait permettre de protéger la
communauté scolaire attendus d'ici moins
de deux semaines maintenant
pendant des travaux des prélèvements
réguliers seront réalisés afin de
s'assurer qu'il n'ya pas d'amiante dans
l'air des précautions sont aussi prises
pour éviter toute contamination par les
ouvriers comme la présence de ces sas
chaque ça c'est une fonction on a le
premier où ils vont aspiré leurs
combinaisons le deuxième où ils vont
prendre une douche habillé le troisième
où ils jetteront tous les vêtements de
travail qu'ils ont utilisé une garderont
que leur masque le quatrième ou y
prendre une douche avec leur masque puis
ensuite une douche d'hygiène et le
cinquième ou pour en mettre un peignoir
et partir pour un temps de repos les
opérations de désamiantage sont devenus
quasi inévitable lors des travaux
effectués par la ctm dans les
établissements scolaires collèges
l'ensemble un colis a fait l'objet d'un
désamiantage le collège edmond pallaro
saint-esprit également et de nombreux
endroits où lorsqu'on travaille dans ces
établissements qui sont antérieurs à 96
eh bien on travaille avec des
entreprises qui sont agréables militer
pour travailler sous section 4
c'est-à-dire souffle sur support amis en
haïti
l'opération devrait durer jusqu'à la fin
du mois d'octobre la destruction est
prévue pour début 2011 20 pour un coût
total de 350 mille euros